The world’s first horror movie begins with
a bat flying into a castle then magically
turning into a caped demon figure known as
Mephistopheles.
It ends with Mephistopheles being chased out
by someone holding a crucifix.
Okay, the Shining or Exorcist, it is not.
But this 1896 film entitled Le Manoir du Diable
(or “The Haunted Castle”) directed by
legendary film visionary Georges Méliès
is generally considered the first horror movie
ever created.
Featuring a boiling cauldron, a tiny minion,
phantoms, a skeleton, apparent suicide from
one of the terrified characters, and even
a witch, it certainly hits a few of the tropes
we are accustomed to seeing in today’s scary
movies.
The film’s (for the time) state-of-the-art
special effects also adds thrills.
And all of these screams are delivered in
a runtime of just under three minutes.
It’s generally accepted that the first “movie”
ever was Eadweard Muybridge’s groundbreaking
1878 “Horse in Motion,”, which we’ve
covered in fascinating depth here.
But the method used to capture the images
used in that one was essentially just high-speed
photography using multiple cameras.
The result was more or less what we’d think
of as a very short animated gif, than a movie.
It all changed, however, when Thomas Edison
visited Muybridge’s studio sometime in the
mid-1880s.
Taking a keen interest in Muybridge’s groundbreaking
work, but unimpressed by his execution, Edison
began to develop a device that “would do
for the eye what the phonograph does for the
ear.”
Around 1889, the Kinetograph debuted out of
Edison’s West Orange lab.
Despite Edison’s claims that he was the
one who invented what many hail as the first
camera to photograph motion pictures, historians
generally attribute Edison’s assistant,
William Kennedy Laurie Dickson, as the creator
of this history-making invention.
In 1890, Dickson shot a test movie he entitled
Monkeyshines No. 1, featuring the movements
of another lab assistant, with the result
being like something a ghost hunter would
use as “proof” that evil spirits are lurking,
rather than like the films that would soon
start to come out.
Nevertheless, it’s generally given credit
for being the first official video camera
motion picture in history.
It also inspired Edison to build what was
perhaps the first movie studio near his West
Orange lab.
Calling it “Black Maria” because they
thought it resembled a police wagon, this
is where they shot hundreds of motion pictures
featuring vaudeville, magic shows, boxing
matches, and Wild Wild West stunts – included
among the latter is a video of Annie Oakley
showing off her prodigious skills with a rifle.
From here, motion picture innovation took
off.
In April 1894, the Kinetoscope Parlor opened
in New York City – essentially the first
public movie theater.
Then, there was the first movie projected
for a wide audience, the first on-screen kiss,
and the first theater permanently created
entirely for a film.
In 1895, the Lumières brothers, who made
several groundbreaking advancements of their
own in film and video camera design, became
the first real film auteurs, making and exhibiting
films with short narratives – including
the famed 50-second short Arrivee d’un train
en gare a La Ciotat.
They also debuted the first comedy film featuring
a gardener and his water house.
With their revolutionary technology, the Lumières
brothers began attracting audiences from far
and wide, including shoe-maker-turned-illusionist
Georges Méliès, who attended one of their
screenings in late 1895.
Méliès was born in Paris in 1861 to a shoemaker,
who fully expected his sons to follow in his
footsteps when he retired.
Despite showing an interest in stage performance
at an early age, his father refused to support
him in this career and, after attending school,
Méliès dutifully settled into a career as
a shoe maker.
Soon, though, his father did retire and handed
off the business to his three sons, including
Georges.
Georges still wanted nothing to do with it
and promptly sold his share of the shoe business
to his brothers, using the money (along with
a sizable dowry from his wife) to purchase
an old run-down downtown theater called Robert
Houdin Theater.
Méliès turned the theater into a popular
magic show venue, but he was always looking
for an edge and, upon seeing the Lumières
brothers’ demonstration of their magical
device that showed motion pictures, he attempted
to buy it off of them.
The Lumières refused.
So, Méliès built his own video camera with
the help of an engineer.
Filming his illusions and playing them back
to the audience proved to be a big hit.
He soon took his camera outside, filming street
scenes and creating narratives.
It was supposedly in the autumn of 1896 when
Méliès discovered a significant trick the
camera could play when it jammed up while
filming.
In his own words,
During this minute, the passerby, buses, carriages
had moved of course.
When I projected the film, joined at the place
where the break had occurred, I suddenly saw
a Madeleine-Bastille bus changed into a hearse,
and men changed into women.
The substitution trick, called stop-motion,
had been discovered.
This simple special effect became the basis
for “The Haunted Castle.”
While it’s thought of today as the first
horror movie, Méliès meant the film to be
more surprising and attention-grabbing than
anything else.
The premise is pretty nonsensical, obviously
intended to showcase stunning (for the late
19th century) special effects, rather than
any particular compelling story.
As you can see if you go watch it, throughout
the nearly three minutes, images keep popping
up, disappearing, and turning into other things.
A bat turns into a demon, girls turn into
witches, a bench suddenly has a skeleton,
and the thin air turns into a trident-wielding
goblin.
At the end, a crucifix is used to chase the
demon character out.
Because of this ending and the general garb
of the evil protagonist, not to mention his
ability to turn into a bat, it’s sometimes
described as the first vampire movie.
Notably, Bram Stoker’s Dracula would not
be released until the next year.
Also, of note, one of the women in the film
is Jehanne D’Alcy – who would become Méliès’s
mistress and, later, his second wife.
“The Haunted Castle” is not Georges Méliès’
finest film, however, just a very early effort.
His most lauded work is generally considered
to be A Trip to the Moon, a masterpiece that
is the direct ancestor of every science-fiction
ever made.
It’s fantastical narrative about going to
the moon – including that iconic image of
the moon with a rocket stuck in its eye – has
inspired filmmakers ever since.
Georges_MélièsIn all, Méliès astonishingly
made around 500 films in just 14 years, or
an average of about 1 every 10 days.
Unfortunately, only around 200 of these have
survived since.
While many were more highly regarded than
1896’s Le Manoir du Diable, none but that
can stake the claim as being the first horror
movie ever.
As for Méliès himself, a series of missteps,
an inability to adapt to new film sales models,
and WWI would ultimately see the once extremely
prosperous filmmaker impoverished and working
in a little toy/candy booth in Montparnasse
train station in Paris.
If this story all sounds familiar, perhaps
you’ve seen the film Hugo, which is based
on the book The Invention of Hugo Cabret,
which in turn is loosely based on the life
of Georges Méliès.